this morning Ukraine's military says
Russian forces have stepped up attacks
just days after the U.S and its allies
agreed to send dozens of Tanks Americans
applied High Mar rocket artillery
systems have already played a very
crucial role on this battlefield Deborah
patta spoke with the Ukrainian army
officer who found a way to say thank you
for the weapons
[Applause]
UA supplied High Mars reigning artillery
down on Russian positions deep Behind
Enemy Lines under the command of
Ukrainian Captain Pablo chernovsky we
met chernovsky near the front lines in
eastern Ukraine where his unit has been
operating president zielinski visited
that region last month to award medals
for outstanding bravery to the Troops
what happened next wasn't in the script
with President zielinski shocked
yes the captain told us you could tell
he was shocked
cherniowsky handed his medal straight
back and asked him to give it to
President Biden instead
I wanted to thank him in the U.S he said
hymas have played a huge role in this
war and so the very next day on his
first trip to Washington since the
conflict began zielinski carried out his
orders
is from him undeserved but much
appreciated thank you thank you
on the front line Ukrainian troops say
some of their outdated equipment is no
match for Russian tanks
which is why the Nimble and highly
accurate High Mars sent by the U.S have
proven so invaluable and if you hadn't
received those High Mars what would it
look like in the areas where you've been
fighting
the front line would be very different
he told us
but the story doesn't end there
President Biden had a gift of his own
for the captain a Command coin from the
battlefields of Iraq where his late son
Beau had fought president
I don't have the words to describe how I
feel chernyovsky
the coin was presented to him at a
special ceremony in Parliament back in
Kiev a Talisman he keeps safely stalled
at his parents home he told us for fear
of losing it on the battlefield but far
more important than any number of medals
and coins
weapons and Rockets of course he said
that way the war would be over quicker
a plea from All the President's Men for
CBS mornings Deborah patter chromatosk
eastern Ukraine